according to the left the exceptions
should get to make all the rules on
gender crime and marriage plus the
chicago teachers union decides never to
go back to school and joe biden
addresses the nation on the oh
macron surge i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
thousands of my listeners have already
secured their internet join them at
expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first did you know that you
don't just vote in november you vote
every single month with the money you
spend and the companies you spend it
with so if you're spending money with
like verizon at t t-mobile the truth is
those companies then spend a lot of
money supporting politicians and issues
that you don't necessarily like you
might be funding biden or pelosi or
schumer because again all those
companies give to people like biden
pelosi and schumer but i offer you a
solution pure talk see pure talk as i've
said uses the exact same tower same 5g
network as one of the big companies but
with the peace of mind that you are
supporting a veteran-run business a
business whose employees are right here
in the united states so yes this is one
monthly bill you can be proud to pay and
by the way that bill is going to be
about half of what you would normally be
paying with that big cell phone company
because the average family saves over
800 a year so do this head on over to
peertalk.com find the plan that's right
for you find the phone that's right for
you or just bring it your own then
because they love my listeners enter
promo code ben shapiro you will save 50
off your very first month of coverage
that's puretalk.com promo code ben
shapiro to save 50 on your first month
and hundreds of bucks down the road with
a company you can trust puretalk.com
promo code ben shapiro okay so
there's a phenomenon that has now
cropped up throughout american society
and that phenomenon is that we are
supposed to let the exceptions make the
rules that if somebody just is very
different from every other human that
that person gets to make all the rules
for all the other humans i'm not talking
about individual rights rights that
apply to everyone right rights that that
adhere to everyone what i'm talking
about here are specifically the
overthrow of institutions that are
generated for the benefit of the vast
majority of human beings and that
broadly speaking brings success and
happiness being overthrown because
there's an exception who has not brought
success or happiness by a historic
institution that has been a part of life
for literally centuries for eons
this philosophy which is that if you
don't fit into the box the box must be
changed is the death of society it is
the death of society and it is what is
breaking down pretty much every
institution in our society these days
from religious institutions to
governmental institutions to basic
institutions of life like marriage
all of these institutions were
originally created they i shouldn't say
created they originally evolved because
that is a more accurate way of
describing how these institutions came
about they evolved gradually over time
right as the great economist frederick
hayek suggests wisdom is essentially
just a bunch of things that have
happened and that have stood the test of
time and they've evolved they've changed
gradually over time and so we should
respect those things that have done this
it doesn't mean we can't change them but
it means we have to take some very
serious thought about why we ought to
change these institutions before we
change them and gk chesterton the famous
catholic theologian and philosopher he
he gave what is probably the greatest
description of the difference between
the left and the right he said that if
you are a person of the left and you
walk across a field and you see a fence
in the middle of the field and you have
no idea why the fence is there your
first move is to immediately start
removing the fence and if you're a
person of the right you say to the
person from the left you don't get to
remove the fence until you can explain
to me why the fence was built there in
the first place in other words we have
to accept that there must have been a
reason why things were the way they were
before you just start dismantling it and
maybe you do dismantle it maybe you look
at the institution you say there's a
serious problem with this institution
and now we're going to change it because
we have considered the ramifications of
changing it and we believe that perhaps
times have changed or there's new
evidence or they just got it wrong but
you first have to understand the logic
of why those institutions were built in
the first place we have completely
dispensed with that in western
civilization we have now come to the
point where if one person has a problem
with an institution or a very very
vanishingly small group of people have a
problem with an institution it's the
institution that's wrong the institution
must change
this is dangerous stuff one of the
original fathers of sociology was a guy
named tilcott parsons he's the father of
a school of sociology called
functionalism the basic idea of
functionalism is that institutions stand
the test of time because they are
functional and so when you look at an
institution or when you look at a
societal role you have to consider the
function of that societal role that it
wasn't just an imposition of a
materialist dialectic as the marxists
like to say it was not just something
that came full blown out of someone's
head as rationalists might suggest no
these institutions came about over long
periods of time and then they were very
durable because they were very useful
right they were functional the way that
the tilcott parsons put it he said
institutions are the way that
individuals interact with society right
institutions are the the middle man
between you and society and because you
as an individual living in isolation
you can do whatever you want whatever
you want is what you want if you're
living on a desert island there are not
a lot of rules that apply to you because
there are no other people that it
affects however when you are interacting
with other people
there have to be some militating
institutions there have to be some
institutions in the middle that you can
all sort of agree on and work within the
framework of
he says that social systems are
generally built by individuals
interacting with one another motivated
by the optimization of individual
gratification and happiness as defined
and mediated in terms of a system of
culturally structured and shared symbols
in other words we have to share some
common rules we have to share some
common roles we have to share some
common institutions well if those things
have stood the test of thousands of
years of time then perhaps we shouldn't
be so quick to dispense with them
because one person doesn't like the
rules however what the left suggests is
that
if government is meant to be god right
or if if society at large is meant to be
god-like then these institutions can be
dispensed with we can change the rules
at any time in fact the pathway to a
higher you is to get rid of all of these
rules there's a russoian belief in the
natural goodness of human nature
underlying all this we get rid of all
the roles if we get rid of all the rules
then natural human man will emerge and
we will be freed from all of the all of
the institutions that have burdened us
for so long right as rousseau suggested
man is everywhere born free but men
everywhere should be free but he's born
in chains essentially
and that we are free spirited
individuals and it's only institutions
of society that have chained us down
okay that is completely ass backwards
that is not the way that real life works
and it is not the way that institutions
work the reason i bring this up is
because there's a column in the new york
times today that is just a perfect
example of this and again once you spot
the pattern it is impossible to unspot
the pattern once you spot the pattern
from the left which is there's an
institution let me give you an example
of x person
for whom this institution makes life
more difficult
therefore the institution is bad tear
down the institution
that is the logic that is constantly
used everywhere and always by people who
completely want to restructure society
to the detriment of the vast majority of
humanity we'll get to that in just one
second first
let us talk about the fact that there
are everyday things that you really
don't pay a lot of attention to make a
huge difference in your life right if
you have a pair of shoes the shoes are
uncomfortable you kind of don't worry
about it for a while eventually you're
like you know what i need a new pair of
shoes you get them you're like why
didn't i do that before one of these
things that you probably have never
thought about but you really need to
think about is the sheets that are on
your bed okay the sheets on your bed
you're on those things for like eight
hours a night if you're lucky and they
better be good cause if they're not good
it's wrecking your sleep quality bullet
and branch makes the best sheets on the
market the signature hem sheets from
bowling branch are a bestseller for a
reason they're buttery soft lightweight
organic cotton and a classic sateen
weave for sheets that get softer over
time they're not too hot and they're not
too cool it's a big one for me because i
tend to heat up at night a lot they're
the perfect year-round sheets for most
sleepers they're so good that the
shapiro family got rid of all of our
other sheets we only use bull and branch
bowling branch signature sheets come in
seven beautiful colors in all sizes from
twin all the way on up to california
king
they're made to a higher standard 100
organic cotton ethical production
thoughtful attention to every detail
there's nothing worse than fitted sheets
that don't fit bowling branch offers 17
inch deep fitted sheets and labeled
sides to help you make your bed
beautifully every single time there's
nothing more annoying than you you
actually have to make your bed and then
you put the signature you put the hem
sheets on the bed and they don't fit in
five minutes into your sleep your face
is on your mattress that never happens
with bull and branch because they fit
your bed the way they're supposed to
experience the best sheets you've ever
felt at bullaandbranch.com get 15 off
your first set of sheets when you use
promo code shapiro at checkout that's
bull and branch b-o-l-l and branch dot
com promo code shapiro to get started
okay so the reason i'm talking about the
destruction of institutions is because
pretty much every day now there's an
article in the op-ed section of the
washington post or the new york times or
any other left-wing publication talking
about why a historic institution is bad
for me and therefore the institution
should go away the latest
the latest iteration of this ridiculous
thesis comes courtesy of caitlyn
greenage who is a contributing opinion
writer
for the new york times and she wrote a
piece that's up today titled what does
marriage ask us to give up
and now normally the answer to that is
marriage asks you to sacrifice for
example the possibility of sexual
variety in favor of one partner marriage
asks you to grow up marriage asks you to
give up the possibility of endless
hedonism in pursuit of a deeper and more
profound relationship with one human
being from whom you create children and
create the next generation of civilized
human beings right that's what marriage
asks you to give up that's and tradition
is pretty clear about this
i mean in in every marriage ceremony
every ritual ceremony i'm aware of
there's great talk about what exactly
you are giving up what you are
sacrificing right whether you're talking
about till death do us part or whether
you're talking about in the in the
jewish marriages full-on prenuptial
agreements right the ketubah in a jewish
marriage
actually lists the obligations that men
and women owe to one another in the
actual marital contract which is read
out loud under the chuppah
so it's not as though people who are
familiar with marital tradition are
unaware of the sacrifices that they're
making
this is in fact the goal of the
institution the goal of the institution
of marriage is that men are to sacrifice
sexual variety for the sake of being
able to build a family and women are
asked to sacrifice the possibility of
mating with another
option in order to settle down and
civilize the man right these are
sacrifices that everybody has known
about throughout all human society when
it comes to the monogamous institution
of marriage according to caitlyn
greenage however she has discovered
something about marriage and that is
that it doesn't it wasn't good for her
therefore we need a new society that
completely dispenses with the idea of
marriage as a norm
now you might say to yourself wait a
second have we been doing that since the
60s and hasn't it paid off with
tremendous downsides for women and men
hasn't it created a society where women
bipolar data are less happy now than
they were in the 1960s
hasn't it created a society where men
are lonelier now and more addicted to
pornography now than they were several
decades ago like where is the great
spate of happiness that has arisen
thanks to the destruction of the
institution of marriage
but again the idea was marriage wasn't
great for everyone therefore marriage
should not be the norm wrong okay the
reason marriage was the norm is because
it is a very useful sociological
institution it is functional it is fully
functional
and once you get rid of it once you set
the standard something else you destroy
the society but again this is the way
the left things so according to caitlin
greenwich quote i spent most of my 20s
and 30s single only to marry and then
come to the conclusion that my marriage
should end now i am single again but i
am not alone my marriage ended during
the pandemic while i was at home with
family since the pandemic began my
daughter and i have been living in what
my family jokingly calls the compound a
house my mom and i bought together
before i was married she and my siblings
and their families lived there in an
attempt to withstand the waves of
gentrification that have displaced
everyone in my family every four to five
years as the sketchy neighborhoods we
afford get discovered by rich young
people the compound is a noisy place
sometimes when everyone is talking and
laughing and joking at once my daughter
who is young enough the language is
still new to her will raise her voice in
a keening screech to try and join the
cacophony living with all this noise has
stirred up many emotions gratitude to my
family for their support the irritation
of adolescents as we sometimes catch
ourselves in the dances of our older
selves a longing for sleep that can only
be felt in a household full of children
who are all awake and ready to play by 6
30 a.m on a saturday what has not
materialized is the intense loneliness
that people warned me would come with
divorce it was always interesting
telling people about the divorce some
friends with small children almost
panicked about what would come about how
the separation was too rash but i am
lucky and that most of my friends have
lived lives of falling in and out of
partnerships you can go it alone you
know was the much more common response
we are living through a time when all
the stories the larger culture tells us
about ourselves are being rewritten the
story of what the united states is what
it means to be a man or woman what it
means to be a child what it means to
love oneself or other people we are
imagining all this again so these
stories can guide and comfort us rather
than control us that paragraph is
leftism in a nutshell we are reimagining
reimagining just out of our own heads
the complete reimagination the complete
destruction of all institutions and
basic facts about human life right from
the value of marriage to the differences
between men and women to what it means
to be a child and we are doing all of
this because there are exceptions to
rules in which people don't enjoy their
marriage and want to get out now first
of all i think it's been a pretty long
standing feature of marriage that there
are some people who don't enjoy it
and this is again not a surprise to
anyone who has read the bible for
example in which there are fairly uh a
lot of number
their fair number of somewhat
dysfunctional marriages right that is
not a a rarity if you read biblical
literature so go back several thousand
years lots of failing marriages that
does not mean that marriage as an
institution is bad nor does it mean
because there are some bad men which
again we've known about for all of human
history this means that man and woman
the definition needs to change right but
the idea is institutions we need to be
liberated from institutions because
there are exceptions to rules except
that when you destroy the institutions
you make people less free
because in order for there to be a
sphere of freedom a sphere of liberty
you cannot live in a fully chaotic world
a fully chaotic world where there are no
rules where there is no framework where
there are no institutions is a
completely unfree world right the man
who is alone on a desert island is maybe
the least free human
because that person has no capacity to
interact with other human beings which
is what brings about huge measures of
happiness
and this is this is something the
philosopher joseph razz has suggested is
that freedom has to exist within
boundaries because if there's no
boundaries there's no freedom
right the boundaries are necessary in
order for you to cultivate relationships
with other people that make you free and
happy
living in a fully chaotic society in
which no one's rights are guaranteed by
any military institutions and in which
there's no support for the social
institutions that allow for the
possibility of human flourishing and
happiness is not freedom it is in fact
slavery whether it is to the chaos
around you or whether it is to the the
drives that you find in your own brain
subjectively changing from day to day
but says it's columnist for the new york
times it's good to get rid of these
institutions because she had a bad
marital experience the the innate
narcissism here is truly astonishing
even as a child i bristled at the
assumptions behind the question that it
was just her mom
bringing her up it seemed obvious to me
then having lived in a two-parent home
that was deeply unhappy and
dysfunctional that the number of parents
around make a working family was
arbitrary that people beholden to the
rigid mathematics of mother and father
and children equal stability were
short-sighted ignoring all we know of
human interactions and ways we make
family throughout human history to
believe that one equation would work for
us all seemed so simplistic and childish
that for much of my young adulthood i
simply disregarded it again that
sentence is so telling it's such a
deeply
it truly is a profound philosophical
essay this thing in the new york times
but not in the way that the author
thinks it is
when she says to believe one equation
would work for us all seemed simplistic
and childish no one said marriage works
for every single human
what we all said is that marriage is an
important institution that facilitates
the bringing up of the next generation
within a stable two-parent household
and that is true for the vast majority
of humans not for all humans
but the converse is not get rid of the
institution right she says
the equation doesn't work for everybody
but the solution to that is not
therefore no equation the answer is
that's true there are free radicals
there are people for whom this does not
work
and those people we are not forcing them
to get married but if society is to get
rid of the institutions in favor of a
different equation which is no equation
then there is no formula for happiness
whatsoever and if you believe that you
subjectively can create your own level
of happiness without any sort of
military societal institutions good luck
to you and more importantly good luck to
the society you've helped to fragment
and destroy
atomistic individualism is the
destruction of society i'm an
individualist insofar as i believe that
freedom is deeply important that
self-definition is a very important
aspect of freedom but it is not the only
aspect of freedom
it is one one among others and some of
those others include the civilizing
institutions that make you fully human
we'll get to more of this in just one
moment first if you're in an e-commerce
business you know the most agonizing
part could be something like responding
to where's my package emails or
processing returns dealing with
expensive shipping charges well
stamps.com takes the pain out of
shipping by giving you access to deeply
discounted shipping options and
integrating with the most popular online
shopping platforms to make labeling a
breeze you can now set yourself up to
focus on the good stuff this year by
saving time and money on shipping with
stamps.com here at daily wire we have
been using stamps.com since 2017 so we
have like a five-year track record at
this point of saving money with sams.com
you should do the same stamps.com has
negotiated deeply discounted rates for
you get up to 40 off usps rates and up
to 76 off ups it integrates with the
most popular online marketplaces and
shopping carts including amazon etsy
shopify and ebay stamps.com
automatically connects you to your
online stores and brings in the shipping
information for all your orders simply
print your shipping label from any
standard printer stick them to your
package then schedule a pickup or drop
them off no traffic no lines for over 20
years stamps.com has helped over a
million businesses save time and money
on shipping start saving time and money
on shipping today stamps.com no risk
with my promo code shapiro you got a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus free postage digital shipping
scale no long-term commitment no
contracts just go to stamps.com click
that microphone at the top of the home
page type in shapiro that is stamps.com
promo code shapirostamps.com easy
ecommerce shipping for less all right so
back to this piece in the new york times
because again it goes to something deep
that is happening in western
civilization the destruction of
civilizing institutions on the basis
that we are all freely acting atomistic
individuals who get to define reality
around us
now the reality is that they are trying
to set a set of rules so the lie is well
we don't want any rules wrong they do
want to rule the rule is that marriage
is actually an act of bad and we have to
rethink the institutions such that we
actually actively discourage marriage or
at the very least we are indifferent to
whether marriage is a positive good that
does restructure society
in a wide variety of contexts this is
this is a great distinction that we have
to make
okay how you treat individuals who don't
fit into the box is a different thing
from saying that the box itself needs to
be exploded
when you explode the box that is not a
neutral standard
okay because you have still created an
institution now it's an institution that
is indifferent as to whether marriage
occurs whether marriage does not occur
indifference
is not a neutral standard human beings
do require institutions that support
particular decisions that we as a
society believe
and and have historically believed
facilitate human flourishing
you get rid of everything a neutral
standard is not no standard a neutral
standard is a standard but it's a
standard that is opposed to the
institutions that existed before
uprooting offense
means that you have uprooted there was a
fence there and now there is no longer
offense there
that has consequences to pretend that as
a return to neutrality is of course very
silly the status quo is what is neutral
right now the question is is uprooting
not going to make it better or make
things worse
okay there's only two directions on this
on this particular treadmill right it
goes forward it goes backwards that's it
there is no okay we have rooted the
institution and now things just stay
nope that's not how life works okay so
this columnist for the new york times
says there's a lot of handwringing
currently about the decline of marriage
in the united states no matter the
divorce rates have also gone down and
that when people are marrying it is it
later ages our culture may have changed
to allow for other ways for people to
chart their lives but whole industries
and institutions banking real estate
healthcare insurance advertising and
most important taxation revolve around
assumptions of marriage as the norm
without that base assumption the logic
of many of these transactions is thrown
out it can feel daunting to come up with
new narratives about what it means to
mature to be worthy of housing and
financial stability and healthcare to
find companionship or emotional support
when these industries have so much
invested both financially and
ideologically in a particular way of
measuring life and community okay so
what this columnist is doing now is
making the marxist move this is a
marxist materialist move so marriage is
not an institution that has existed
across societies for thousands of years
marriage is instead an imposition of the
materialist capitalist class upon
everybody else and if you blow it up
then you can completely remake humanity
in brand new exciting directions it's
the insurance companies creating
marriage
it is it is the capitalist
infrastructure creating marriage
it's the powers that be no
it is not
no it isn't
so says this this columnist for the new
york times in search of new narratives i
have found myself drawn to diane de
prima's 2001 memoir recollections of my
life as a woman it focuses on her
childhood and life in new york a
portrait of the artist as a young woman
and all her romantic and intuitive glory
mr prima is remarkable because as a poet
in her early 20s in 1950s new york she
decided she wanted to be a mother and a
single mother at that
well
great i mean except for the kid who now
lacks a father but apparently this means
she's virtuous because again she didn't
fit in the box and the box is always bad
according to the left her memoir
revolves around this conflict between
motherhood and the demands of an artist
at a certain point overwhelmed by the
demands of parenting children alone
while running a press founding an
avant-garde theater protecting her
left-wing friends from raids by the fbi
and the grinding poverty of an artist's
life in new york city at no point by the
way do we have any discussion of the
impact of this on the child mr prima
entered into a marriage of convenience
with a man she distrusted he was the
ex-boyfriend of her male best friend
besides its messy origins this
relationship resembles the dream i've
heard so many straight women describe in
a joking not joking way wishing to start
a family with a friend to avoid the
complications of romantic love but mr
prima is honest about the limitations of
the arrangement she wrote that she
avoided the pains of romance but the man
she married is still a domineering
abusive mess in her recounting
furthermore in marriage she has lost
something integral to herself quote one
of my most precious and valued
possessions was my independence my
struggle for control over my own life i
didn't see that it had no intrinsic
value for anyone but myself that it was
a coin that was precious only within the
realm a currency that could not cross
borders
says the columnist for the new york
times these words when i read them
sounded in me like the chime of a tuning
fork because again all of society is
about her right all the rules have to be
changed for her she is the only person
in the world
those who panic over the rise in the
number of single americans do not see
that this statistic includes lives of
hard-won independence lives that still
intersect with a community with a home
with a belief in something wider than
oneself the people clinging to old
narratives around singledom and marriage
can't yet see these lives for what they
are because as mr prima puts it they are
not an objectively valuable commodity
their meaning is a currency that cannot
cross borders these lives threaten the
communal narratives currently in place
but what is a threat to some can be to
others a glimmer of a new world coming
ah that's the key right the communal
narratives which we would normally refer
to as societal institutions that promote
human flourishing those need to go away
and so if you live life in
in direct conflict with those
institutions you are living your life
politically right your life is now a
political act this is why the personal
is political for the left left believes
that if you live your life in these ways
that you are striking a blow against
whatever institution they don't like the
patriarchy
marriage capitalism
and there's only one problem when you
blow up these institutions institutions
don't go away you just get new
institutions and they are much much much
worse because when people live together
there have to be rules and shared
frameworks and somebody has to design
those rules and shared frameworks either
it can be the wisdom of ages passed down
generation over generation gradually
attuned by human reason and by the
wisdom of experience or it can be a
bunch of morons who have decided that
their subjective pleasure is more
important than actual institutions that
have helped create human happiness over
the course of thousands of years
that's what this is about
and and you can see this
it's present in practical politics the
reason i spend so much time on this is
because as we'll see this applies to a
variety of political issues that affect
your daily life people have decided that
institutions don't matter because
they're the only people on earth who
matter we'll get to this in just one
second first
what is your new year's resolution if
you're like most people there's a box of
your family's treasured home movies and
photos tucked in a closet you've been
meaning to preserve but you weren't sure
where to start legacy box make checking
this off your to-do list very very easy
legacy box is a super simple mail and
service to have all of your video tapes
camcorder tapes film reels pictures
converted to perfectly preserved digital
files plus legacy box is the industry
leader they've helped over a million
customers safeguard their past simply
send your legacy box filled with old
home movies and photos and get back
digital copies that can be easily
enjoyed shared and organized it is
indeed magic so i did this for my
parents it's fantastic i went over to
their house before they moved to florida
they had a bunch of boxes that were
filled with old photos and old film
reels and i sent them all in two legacy
box and they came back all digitally
preserved it's beautiful it's all on the
thumb drive and now they've got it
forever and they could send it around
very easily to me and my sisters it's
fantastic
legacy box has a team of 200 train
technicians waiting to help you with all
of this every purchase includes access
to a personal concierge available seven
days a week to answer all of your legacy
box questions kick off the new year by
rescuing your family's most cherished
memories go to legacybox.com shapiro to
take advantage of an exclusive discount
for listeners that's legacybox.com
shapirogo check them out today okay so
you can see this philosophy carried out
in policy not just in terms of social
policy and sort of approach to social
issues but the left-wing belief that
exceptions ought to make the rules
because after all the rules aren't great
for everyone that belief system ends
with some pretty pathetic ramifications
for all of human society so for example
california has now mandated that every
big box store in california this kicked
in in the new year every big toy store
is required to create a gender-neutral
toy section
why
why so the answer that people will give
you is well you know we need a
gender-neutral toy section for those
kids who who are having trouble with
their gender identity so what you're
really saying is that gender doesn't
exist and what you're really saying is
there's no such thing as biological sex
or human
proclivities that are that are directed
by biological sex or connected to it
right that human tendencies are not
connected to sex in any way we have to
redefine sex across the biological
spectrum to account for the fact that
there are some people who feel
uncomfortable a vast fast fast minority
and this is not how you make a
societal rules right
disassembling basic
ideas of the reality of male and female
that is not the way that you promote
human happiness that is the way you
promote chaos
and the once again the left does not
seem to care about the fact that male
and female are pretty rigid categories
biologically i say pretty i mean
innately rigid categories
and that human activities within those
categories
tend to fall along somewhat
stereotypical lines and that that's not
a bad thing that societally speaking
that's quite a good thing that doesn't
mean that there aren't exceptions to the
rule we ought not treat those people
with tolerance we should but that does
not mean that you redefine gender
entirely and yet this is seen as a
positive good why because there are
exceptions and we have to make sure that
all of society is restructured in favor
of this small group of people who have a
problem with the societal institutions
and there's a good thing by law again
somebody fills the gap folks when you
blow up the institutions something else
fills the gap now it's compulsory
government
gender theory here we go this is a
report from nbc news on the new
california law
this might seem like a silly piece of
typical california politics but the
truth is that big box toy stores across
the country have been moving in this
direction both walmart and target have
done away with gendered toy sections and
experts say that's good because gendered
toys shape how children see themselves
and each other
yep
who are these experts by the way are
they experts who care about human
flourishing absolutely not they're
experts who don't care about the
majority of children flourishing because
it turns out that kids like gender roles
okay this is by the way this is true in
primates as well okay if you find it if
you find female primates female primates
will try to comfort they'll turn random
objects into dolls and they'll try to
comfort them and male primates will turn
everything into a weapon
they'll look for machines this is true
for monkeys it's also true for human
beings it turns out that gender roles
are quite good for kids kids like rules
kids like to be told that there are
gender roles and that
what they have are specifically created
biological powers that merge with
civilizational institutions that
re-inculcate very important things about
humanity that boys grow up to be men are
supposed to be protectors and guardians
and that girls grow up to be women are
supposed to be creators and nurturers
this does not mean that women can't also
be protectors and guardians or that men
can't also be nurturers it does mean
that there are stereotypical attributes
to masculinity and femininity which by
the way even the trans community
acknowledges which is why they attempt
to adopt the stereotypical garb of the
opposite sex in order to claim
membership in it very often right have
surgeries to effectuate that change
the the
but the experts say that the
institutions are bad why are they bad i
have a question why are they bad were
there really a huge huge number of kids
so deeply disaffected by societal
institutions around gender like huge
numbers of kids who walked into toy
stores and just started weeping because
the barbies were in the girls section
and the guns the nerf guns were in the
boys section were there like was it was
this an overwhelming societal problem or
was it that experts don't like the
institutions because all institutions
are militating factors in favor of
civilizational
things
that are that are good and positive and
they don't like the civilization itself
and they want to remold the civilization
itself who are these experts
why why are they experts on kids what
makes them an expert
truly what even makes them an expert on
human happiness in order to direct
policy you have to determine what is the
good you are seeking with the policy for
whom are you seeking this good
it is pretty obvious here the good that
they are seeking for society is tearing
down roles because roles are inherently
bad because we are all malleable widgets
and if you get rid of societal roles you
can remake humanity as essentially a
piece of clay in the mold that you wish
to remake it
that is utopian nonsensical dream that
always ends in tyranny always utopianism
ends in tyranny
there's a point that carl popper made
and he happens to be correct
it's not just with regard to things like
gender
and people why do you even care why
the same reason you care the same reason
you do you made a you made a law guys
okay so you cared enough to make a law
compelling toy stores to have
gender-neutral toy sections don't tell
me i shouldn't care about that when
you're openly saying you wish to remold
society and destroy societal
institutions okay but it's not just with
regard to things like men and women it's
also with regard to things like crime so
the entire criminal policy of the left
of the hard left is that there are
certain people who they don't think
should be in jail therefore no one
should be in jail apparently according
to the new york post manhattan's new d.a
has now ordered his prosecutors to stop
seeking prison sentences for hordes of
criminals and to downgrade felony
charges in cases including armed
robberies and drug dealing according to
a set of progressive policies made
public on tuesday
in his first memo to staff on monday
alvin bragg said his office quote will
not seek a carceral sentence meaning put
people in jail except for homicide in a
handful of other cases including
domestic violence felonies some sex
crimes and public corruption
this rule may be accepted only in
extraordinary circumstances based on
holistic analysis of the facts criminal
history victim's input and any other
information available the memo reads
assistant da's must also now keep in
mind the impacts of incarceration
including whether it really does
increase public safety potential future
barriers to convicts involving housing
and employment the financial cost of
prison and
and the racial disparities over who gets
time now again we are making rules for
the entire society based on a small
minority of people who commit criminal
acts that's what we are doing
and by the way minorities are the
minorities because when we talk about
are there too many black men going to
prison that is still a vast minority of
black men the vast majority of black men
do not go to prison
and there's this baseline idea that we
have to completely reshape how criminal
law and institutions of justice are done
in this country because you don't like
the outcome for a minority of humans who
decide to commit crimes is patently
crazy
but that is what they are seeking to do
because the idea is that we have created
a quote unquote carceral society and our
constitutional society is having
downstream effects that shape how people
live and we don't like how those people
are living and therefore we have to get
rid of these institutions all together
we've done that but guess what replaces
it chaos when you get rid of
institutions you create new institutions
those new institute institutions either
foster chaos or foster tyranny or both
when it comes to criminal law the left
has fostered absolute anarchy chaos
which is why you've seen mass increases
in murder rates across major cities in
the united states because prosecutors
have decided that they are not
interested in prosecuting people on
behalf of the small minority so just as
the institution of marriage must be
destroyed because there are some people
who don't like it and they don't fit
within the box and the the institutions
of law must be destroyed because there
are some people who don't like the law
and commit crimes
and the institution of gender must be
destroyed because there are some people
who feel uncomfortable
and of course we have to destroy the
institution of schooling as well because
there are some people who feel
uncomfortable so for example the chicago
public schools have now canceled all
classes because the union voted to go
virtual now we have been told by the
biden administration
that public sector unions are a are a
fulsome good they are excellent and we
need public sector unions that bargain
against the taxpayer
we need this they're very important
and we need to make sure that these
teachers who are the heroes of the
pandemic after i mean soldiering on
soldiering on from their homes and
apartments doing zoom classes to a bunch
of kids who aren't watching them they
are the true heroes they are they are
truly the heroes now listen there are
some teachers who actually tried to go
back into school and those people
are just as heroic as everybody else who
went to work no more no less you're not
more heroic for having gone into a
school than the guy is for having gone
into a factory or even the banker is for
having gone into his office today
this silliness where teachers are more
heroic than every other member of the
population is really foolish when it
comes to omicron when it comes to when
it comes to covet generally considering
that kids are not getting sick
you're more likely to get sick
at your local factory working than you
are likely to get sick at your local
school working this has been true
throughout the pandemic by the way
in fact you remember that last summer
when delta was beginning to spike
there's all this thought well if we
reopen schools teachers are going to get
sick and it turned out that every story
that was coming up about teachers dying
was from a teacher who got infected
outside of school
and well now the chicago teachers union
the greatest of all people who are
running the biden administration by the
way randy weingarten is in the white
house every other minute
the chicago teachers union voted to
teach virtually rather than in the
classroom because of course these are
heroes heroes of the republic cps is the
third largest school district in the
country they resumed in-person learning
on monday in conditions that union
leaders described as unsafe
the union held an emergency meeting on
tuesday the vote was 73 percent in favor
of the remote work only job action the
union said on twitter
chicago chicago public schools described
the union vote as quote an unfortunate
decision
the union said the action will end when
the current surging cases substantially
subsides
okay so just a quick note this is an
illegal strike okay by by law public
sector unions are not allowed to strike
the reason they're not allowed to strike
is because they're not striking against
an employer they're striking against the
taxpayer public sector unions are barred
from strikes by law doesn't matter they
do it all the time okay but again the
idea is the rules must change the rules
must change because there's a small
group of people who are paranoid and
being crazy
and so all the rules have to change to
restrict students from being able to go
to school
and and this is the way that all of this
works now
on the other end of this
you know that what people on the left
will say is well yeah but you on the
right you guys you you also want you
know a few people to rule the roost in
terms of the in terms of the prevailing
societal rules you're not doing it for
the broad spectrum of humanity
okay and what they will mention is for
example vax mandates they'll say why why
are you why aren't you in favor of axe
mandates fax mandates vaccinations are
good for the vast majority of people so
why are you saying that we shouldn't
mandate vaccinations first of all
nothing i've said in here says that
marriage ought to be compulsory for
example
or that gender
gender segregated toy stores gender
separated toy stories ought to be
compulsory okay so the use of government
compulsion is one factor that militates
here the other is the nature of rights
so there is a very big difference
between rights that adhere to every
individual and that you choose to
exercise when you get a vaccine or don't
get a vaccine
and the collective
institutions that we share as a society
there's
rights exist within certain boundaries
and one of those rights is the right to
say i don't wish to vaccinate myself
because my health is
essentially my business
but according to lori lightfoot
it's amazing so what the left will say
is you have no rights when it comes to
your own health
but also we are going to completely
restructure society when it comes to
things like marriage gender and crime
here's lori lightfoot who's done all of
these things saying that businesses love
the vax mandates love them
and what we're hearing from a lot of
folks particularly business people is
they want to create a safe environment
and they're grateful for
us imposing uh this vaccine mandate
in entertainment venues so restaurants
bars gyms
and the like
okay imposing actual coercive measures
on individuals is a very different thing
from there being societal institutions
that we foster and uphold
okay to understand what rights are you
have to think about rights within a
framework when we think about rights
generally like for example the right not
to get a vaccine
right you have to determine you know
what rights apply do which rights obtain
you have to be pretty specific about how
rights work we're going to get into that
in just a second because when we use the
language of rights very often we are
unclear about what exactly we are
talking about and i think it's kind of
important to clarify so we'll get into
that in just one moment first let's talk
about the fact that you're spending too
much on gas because you are spending too
much on gas this is why you need that
free app i've been talking about get
upside my listeners are making up to 25
cents for every gallon of gas every time
they fill up just download that free get
upside app in the app store or google
play right now use promo code shapiro
get a bonus 25 cents per gallon on your
first fill up that's up to 50 cents cash
back do not pay full price of the pump
anymore get cash back right now using
get upside just download the app for
free use promo code shapiro get up to 50
cents per gallon cash back on your first
tank of gas some people who drive a lot
are making as much as two to three
hundred bucks a month in cash back there
is no catch the cash back gets added
directly to your account you can cash
out any time to your bank account paypal
or an egift card for amazon and other
brands just download that free getupside
app use promo code shapiro to get up to
50 cents per gallon cashback on your
first tank of gas that is promo code
shapiro go check out that free get
upside app right now you're spending too
much for gas bring that price of gas
down super easily 50 cents per gallon
cash back every gallon of gas for your
first tank of gas when you use promo
code shapiro and 25 cents per gallon
when on all the subsequent gallons of
gas using that free get upside app right
now alrighty we'll get some more on this
in just one second first
if you're looking for some motivation to
start your year off strong look no
further than the brand new book club
that i am launching once a month i will
be reading a book with you i'm gonna
recommend a book that has earned an
important place in our society in the
history of western civilization
some of these books have been chased out
of the classroom they are key pillars in
the foundations of the united states and
of western civilization more generally
not only will the book club hold you
accountable for each new read you'll
also get exclusive access to my personal
notes and analysis and then on the third
thursday of each month i will join
dailywire members online for an in-depth
lecture and discussion of each book
you're not going to want to miss it just
head on over to third
thursdaybookclub.com that is t-h-i-r-d
thursday book thursdaybookclub.com and
join me i mean i'm really excited about
this i've been reading the books in
preparation you'll receive this month's
book recommendations and some of the
materials you'll need to participate in
our first members only discussion on
january 20th when you head on over to
third thursdaybookclub.com
and put in your email address to get
started today and start the new year off
right you know you want to read more you
want to read better check out third
thursdaybookclub.com and join me in that
quest also as you know this friday the
supreme court is going to convene to
hear arguments on the legality and
constitutionality of the biden
administration's absurdly tyrannical
vaccine mandate that means this week is
going to be huge for the lawsuit that we
have filed against the biden
administration and medical tyranny
already over 1 million people have
signed our do not comply petition we
would love to increase that number
vastly before friday help us send our
message loud and clear head on over to
dailywire.com do not comply and help us
push back against the tyrannical vax
mandate from the biden administration
you are listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
okay so let's talk for a second about
rights so what the left is constantly
doing is they're cramming down from
above their version of society what they
suggest of course is that they're not
they're just upholding rights okay but
the question is what is a right right
what is the right you know is is it a
right for you to have a gender-neutral
toy section is it a right for criminals
to walk free like what constitutes a
right and how does that differentiate
from for example your right to medical
freedom right not to get a vaccine if
you don't want a vaccine again i'm a big
proponent of the vaccines i in fact i
think that there are certain
circumstances in which the government
can compel vaccination i think
particularly for childhood diseases you
know in the context of public schools if
you wish to take part in a public school
and this is a childhood disease like
measles mumps rubella i have no problem
whatsoever with school districts
mandating that you get your shots before
you go to school because these are
childhood diseases the the destruction
of the disease requires that children
get the shot and not transmit it to one
another at the public school level for
example right so how do you determine
when a right obtains and pertains how do
you determine that so in order to
discuss what a right is we first have to
get more specific about this because
people use rights in many different ways
right if you talk to the left there's a
quote unquote right to housing that's a
very different thing than saying i have
a right to free speech a right to free
speech means no one has the power to
compel me to say anything a right to
housing means i can compel you to give
me housing i have to compel somebody to
give me housing i have a right to
housing because we're not talking about
a right to obtain housing at a fair at a
fair price we're talking about a right
to have a house
right so this is what isaiah berlin
determined the difference between
positive liberty and negative liberty a
positive liberty a positive right is
you're being given something a negative
right is i have a right against you to
prevent you from harming me for example
right there's a pretty strict difference
but we can get more specific than that
and when we talk about rights we should
keep a framework of what exactly we're
talking about in our mind because it
determines what government can do and
what government can't and what our moral
duties are and what they aren't so
there's a famous legal scholar from the
early 20th century he used to teach at
yale law school his name is wesley
newcomb hoefeld okay and wesley newcomb
hofeld had essentially a a four-part
analysis of what a right could be there
are four types of rights that he talks
about first what he calls privileges so
privileges are things that we don't have
a duty to do
and so for example i have a privilege
not to eat a hamburger today it's a i
have no moral duty not to eat a
hamburger i have no moral duty to eat a
hamburger i have a privilege to decide
whether or not to eat a hamburger
because there's no more there's no moral
duty compelling me to eat or not eat
that hamburger
okay so that is so i have a privilege
if i don't have a duty
to to
to do that thing
so i have a privilege to hamburger if
there's no duty not to eat the hamburger
for example then there are claims so a
claim is a right that i can claim
against you so for example
if you have a duty to feed your child
your child has a claim against you
your child
has an actual real life claim against
you because you have a duty to feed your
kid so your child can say you have a
duty to feed me you have violated your
duty therefore i have a claim against
you this is a kind of right
okay then there are powers powers are
the ability of some overarching
authority to change the nature of
privileges and claims
so for example an employer can order a
contract an employee to stay late at
work
right they have the power to do that and
they have the power to do that because
normally i couldn't force you to just
stay at your job right i have no
relationship with you so i can't force
you to stay at your job beyond a certain
number of hours for example but your
employer has the power to change your
work duties because you've contracted to
your employers you have powers okay so
that's the third type of right power
okay and finally the fourth type of
right is immunity immunity is where and
you say an institution does not have the
power so this is what we are generally
talking about when we're talking about
vax mandates so you can say two things
at once one i think in certain certain
circumstances you probably have a moral
duty to yourself and to others to get
vaccinated for example if you're
immunocompromised in 75 i think that you
have a pretty strong moral duty to get
vaccinated okay now that is a different
thing from saying that the government
has the power to compel you to get
vaccinated you have an immunity against
the government why because we don't want
to give the government the full-scale
authority to reshape how we all live we
don't want to give the government the
full-scale prudential authority on a
prudential level right as a matter of
what we would like the government to
have the government should not have the
ability to reshape all aspects of our
health life for our own benefit
so we have immunity against government
so you can say that you have an immunity
without for example having the privilege
like you may have a moral duty on sort
of a moral general level that you should
protect yourself and you should you
should make yourself healthier i can say
both those things at once
okay so for the left they don't believe
that for the left they believe that
there is no such thing as an immunity
from a thing that they wish you to do
so if they wish you to do something then
they ought to be able to compel it
for them every
lack of privilege every time you have a
moral duty to do something they have the
power to compel it
okay that is not something i think with
most with which most americans agree
and yet that is the going theory among
people on the left and and by the way
people are running headlong from places
that impose these sorts of things
anything that is not prohibited
is is now compulsory according to the
left
every single thing
right as long as you're not prohibited
from an activity it must be a compulsory
activity
this is this is the way that they think
and people are fleeing these states
there's a good piece in the wall street
journal today talking about how people
are fleeing these states so for example
where are people leaving and where are
people going
according to the national movers study
released monday by united van lines the
largest netge net gain in terms of share
of move-ins was vermont 74 percent of
moves were inbound the rest of the top
five south dakota south carolina west
virginia and florida
one of those common themes is
affordability another one of those
common themes is safety
nearly half of the moves into vermont
and florida or among households earning
more than 150 000 a year moving away
from higher priced spots in the
northeast new jersey was the biggest
loser 71 percent of its moves were
headed out of state
67 percent of moods concerning illinois
were out of state new york 63
connecticut 60 california 59
people are leaving blue states they're
heading on over to cheaper and better
states and less repressive states
states that have strong social
institutions but not a lot of compulsion
the left doesn't believe in either of
those things they don't like the strong
social institutions which they say hem
humanity in and they also love
compulsion because again
anything that is not prohibited is
compulsory according to the left
so
this is resulting in some pretty
ramifications when it comes to
everything from
gender to to crime to covid
right they have to compel you to do what
they want to do the bottom line is
their view of life requires tyranny
because social institutions are an
excellent militating force against
tyranny things like marriage and family
militate against total governmental top
down control
things like church militate against
total top down governmental control
because social pressure is a great force
for
social binding when you don't have that
when you blow up all those institutions
the government has to create
the air sats the fake level of social
cohesion necessary in order for society
to operate you can only do that with
top-down compulsion so they blow up the
institutions on behalf of a small group
of people who don't like the
institutions or for whom the
institutions are not beneficial
and then they replace that with
governmental compulsion
of a new form of social cohesion and
then they are shocked when people leave
and don't like this and move instead to
places where there's more social
cohesion places where there are a set
set of social institutions and rules and
where freedom exists within those social
institutions the great irony of life is
that the stronger the social
institutions the greater the freedom the
weaker the social institutions the less
the freedom because the government must
create some sort of social cohesion and
they can only do that with the billy
club
that is the only way the government
creates social cohesion
so
joe biden right now is trying to happy
talk his way through this thing he tried
compulsion it didn't work when it came
to when it came to vaccines he has tried
everything he can think of in order to
create air social cohesion top-down
well-wrecking institutions on behalf of
wokeness and redistributionism and now
he's going to happy talk his way through
this thing so yesterday joe biden went
out there in the middle of an economy in
limbo and an omicron surge and what he
could say is listen we have great social
institutions in this country we have
people we have hospitals we have
communities we have people who take care
of each other and we have freedoms and
we have vaccines that are available to
you
we have all these things available to
you go out and live your life happily in
a free country instead joe biden is
trying to happy talk his way through his
own failures of ideology
so first of all it's it's always fun to
watch the current president of the
united states not know what year it is
that's that's exciting
this house plan president house plan
over here hiding the water stain that is
the democratic party agenda things are
going poorly here was the president of
the united states yesterday he was
giving an emergency speech on covid in
which he said absolutely nothing of
value here he was saying that it is 2020
which is a surprise to most of us
we're going to get through this
we're going to get through it together
we have the tools to protect people from
severe illness due to omicron
if
people choose to use the tools
we have the medicines coming along that
can
save so many lives and dramatically
reduced the impact that coveted has had
on our country
there's a lot of reason to be hopeful in
but for god's sake
please take advantage of what's
available
okay so encouraging people you have
accident i have no problem with
but alarming people unduly about the
nature of human life what we have is a
is a pandemic of panic among the
vaccinated so joe biden said yesterday
that this is a pandemic of the
unvaccinated uh realistically speaking
it is not a pandemic of the unvaccinated
anymore it is pandemic of everybody now
it may be a lot of hospitalizations and
death among the unvaccinated that is
true the vast majority of
hospitalizations and deaths that are
currently occurring in the united states
are of unvaccinated people when it comes
to omicron it also happens to be that
omicron is hitting a huge swath of the
population like over a million positive
tests yesterday in the united states
five times the number last year and
somewhere in the same range of deaths on
a daily basis which means this thing
thank god is significantly less deadly
like up to five times less deadly than
delta according to the south african
data
and so joe biden is trying to panic
everyone what he should be saying is no
one should be panicked at this point if
you're unvaccinated and you've never had
coveted before then you should be
you should be concerned particularly if
you're immunocompromised or elderly
should be concerned and maybe you should
go get a vaccine
but otherwise everybody should get back
to daily life and stop testing
asymptomatically or if you have a cold
it's silly he's not going to do any of
that because again he's invested in the
idea that government can change
everything government is going to force
you to be a good citizen so here is joe
biden saying that this is a pandemic of
the of the unvaccinated and if you are
vaccinated you should be concerned but
if you're unvaccinated you should be
setting your hair on fire what he's
actually doing is creating a panic of a
pandemic panic among the vaccinated i
gotta tell you it's amazing i mean i'm
speaking to people all over the country
on a regular basis the only people who
are panicked are people who are fully
vaccinated and boosted living in blue
states
those that's the entirety of the people
who are panicked there is no one who is
unvaccinated at this point who's
panicked because if they were panicked
they already got they already would have
gotten vaccinated
it's not everybody who's vaccinated
who's panicked i'm not panicked i don't
care i'm done
right i'm i i've been done since i got
the vax
and my parents have been done since they
got the vaccine boosted and my wife is
vaccine boosted so i like i don't know
what there is to panic about but the
only people in america who are panicking
right now are people who are boosted
boosted again 80 of their body weight is
now vaccine and they're still panicking
about omicron that's because of this
dullard here's here's president biden
we're seeing covet 19 cases among
vaccinated workplaces across america
including here at the white house but if
you're vaccinated and boosted you are
highly protected
you know
be concerned about omicron but don't be
alarmed
but if you're unvaccinated you have some
reason to be alarmed many of you will uh
you know uh
you'll experience severe illness many
cases if you get covet 19 if you're not
vaccinated
some will die needlessly die
okay again i'm a fan of vaccines and i
think vaccines are good but you know
what to be great here is some actual
statistical data which is available to
the president of the united states
meanwhile joe biden says he believes
that schools should remain open which
comes as news to the chicago teachers
union he has yet to tweet about the
chicago's teachers union shutting down
all schooling in the city of chicago
we know that our kids can be safe when
in school by the way
that's why i believe schools should
remain open
you know
they have what they need
because of the american rescue plan
where the first month we were in office
or second month
that i signed in march the states and
the school districts
have spent this money well many of them
but unfortunately some haven't
so i encourage the states and school
district to use the funding that you
still have to protect your children and
keep the schools open
okay weird because it's your party
that's shutting down schools right now
also joe biden feb he says that
hospitals are being overrun
thanks to the unbax so first of all the
data on hospitals being overrun is
really scanty okay maybe hospitals are
being strained in some places like rural
parts of the country but if they are
being overrun it turns out that that is
probably due to the fact that there are
a bunch of people who are not working
according to maria raven and gene noble
writing for the wall street journal
the united states currently has a severe
shortage of nurses and healthcare
workers are suffering from significant
burnout compounded by understaffing as
the omicron variant spreads outdated
covenant testing and quarantine policies
are exacerbating health care worker
shortages
it turns out that when you vax mandate a
bunch of people who already have natural
immunity and they work in hospitals and
they go home and then you have to
activate the national guard in for
example new york in order to staff
hospitals that creates artificial
shortages
according to the wall street journal
omicron is highly contagious and now
accounts for most infections in the
united states hospitals are increasing
asymptomatic testing of their employees
and requiring those with potential
exposure to quarantine even if they have
no symptoms and a negative test
in light of that staffing crisis the cdc
last week reduced the isolation period
for covet-infected healthcare workers to
five days but now they're saying well
maybe you should think about getting a
test anyway before you go back to work
but here's joe biden again suggesting
that this crisis is not brought about by
his own stupid policy it's instead
crisis that's been brought about by the
people he can always blame the unboxed
countries across the world have seen
rising cases here in the united states
our team have been working around the
clock during the holiday weeks
in the last two weeks we have developed
hundreds of military that we have
deployed i should say hundreds of
military doctors and nurses to staff the
hospitals in our states that are overrun
and overworked because one vaccinated
covered 19 patients primarily
okay well maybe it's because they're a
shortage of workers created by your
federal vaccine mandates and you're
having to fill in using the military
also joe biden keeps saying things about
testing he's just incompetent the level
of competence in this administration is
truly astonishing it's just unbelievable
incompetence here's joe biden saying you
know what why don't you go try to find a
free covet test nearby oh yeah good luck
with that by the way we have a massive
kova test shortage
google
quote covet test near me
go there google excuse me kova test near
me on google
to find the nearest site where you can
get a test
most often
and free
look
with more capacity for in-person tests
we should see waiting lines shortened
and more appointments freed up
i'm seeing literal lines of cars for
blocks because of the stupid
restrictions that he's put down about
how you have to test before you go back
to work and about how we have to test
the asymptomatic then he didn't supply
the test my favorite part of this is
that joe biden says that the testing
shortages are very frustrating to him
are they though because i feel like joe
biden can get a test are they deeply
frustrating to joe biden
this adult this adult old man my
goodness
on testing
i know this remains frustrating believe
me it's frustrating to me
but we're making improvements
in the last two weeks we've stood up
federal testing sites all over the
country
we're adding more each and every day
uh yeah and you should have been doing
that what like a year ago i mean really
like as soon as he became president i
thought this was his first priority
talked about it repeatedly we need more
testing this is not unexpected by the
way what we actually need is fewer
people testing if you're asymptomatic
you should not be testing if you have a
mild cold you should not be testing just
assume that everyone's gonna get omicron
and move on with your life it is that
simple we are all going to get omnicron
for most of us it's going to be
asymptomatic or a mild coal if we are
vaccinated it's going to provide you
exorbitantly small levels of of harm in
terms of hospitalization and or death
but he can't let go he can't do it
he's again for the left everything is
compulsory everything
and so here is chuck schumer who's
trying to happy talk his way through
this thing saying joe biden is doing a
great job on testing which is weird
because everyone knows he's not
i think that they are doing a good job
in terms of getting the tests out i've
asked that more tests be coming to new
york they've sent them they've sent them
there and look what happened covid came
back with a fervor in a far wider way
than we've known but i think the biden
administration is doing a good job on
testing
meanwhile jensaki denied that biden has
lost complete control of the pandemic
apparently things are going swimmingly
if they think they can happy talk their
way through this one i just i they're
they're out of their minds they're crazy
let's be straight here for a second
cases are rising across the country
tests are hard to come by in many places
or there's long lines for them
schools are closing again or having to
go virtual and that's not just because
of the weather in some parts of the
country but because of the pandemic
uh
there is a sense among many that the
country has lost control of the virus
would the white house agree with that
we would not
no of course we wouldn't agree that
we've lost control i mean we just have a
million cases a day you were never in
control guys you just weren't by the way
best thing is that the administration
and the panic the coveted panic porn
people the their big thing has been we
are going to focus in on the kids the
kids are are the ones who are really in
danger the kids are not in danger they
have not been in danger this entire time
now jens hockey says the kids are at
risk because of unvaccinated adults wait
a second i thought that the adults were
at risk because of unvaccinated kids
the logic just changes whenever they
need it to change it's amazing
i think what's important to step back
here is recognize we're still in the
middle of a pandemic
there are still
far too many people who are not
vaccinated there are still kids who are
at risk because there are not enough
people adults vaccinated and i think
what we're all collectively trying to do
here is protect more people and save
more lives whether you work here or at
the cdc or the fda
oh okay so it's about the kids by the
way the today show picking up on this
panic because we basically have a pravda
loop that exists inside the media
anytime the administration says the
thing the immediate response from the
media are
how do we mirror this and just keep
repeating it back to the white house and
the media will be cited by the white
house as justification for their policy
it's a perfect loop here is the today
show yesterday promoting kn95s for
possibly kids
obviously the can 95 and 95 are the most
effective but it can be really hard to
find them in small kid sizes and also to
keep them on your kids all day they're
not the most comfortable so the second
best option is to make sure you have a
kid-sized surgical mask and by the way
look at what a difference the kid size
mask is from the adult side so you
really want to make sure you have one
that fits your child's face
and you want to layer the cloth mask
over that mask so the surgical mask goes
on first and then the cloth mask
um this none of this is scientific none
of this is required none of it
but not according to vivek murthy mythic
murthy is the surgeon general of the
united states here he was yesterday
saying it's time to vax the
five-year-olds five-year-olds are not
dying from covet they are not the number
of kids who have died under age 18 in
the united states remains below 700 for
two years two years of pandemic
all right here we go
i think we have even more work to do
here to get more children vaccinated
we've done we've been more than 200
million people vaccinated fully
vaccinated in our country millions who
are boosted but kids saying i had
vaccines authorized later for them you
know because the studies took longer to
do and that was important to do
thoroughly but now we've got to really
push put our foot on the accelerator get
our kids who are five and above
vaccinated uh it's more critical than
ever
you're all insane you're all insane so
because a minority of people in the
united states are deeply panicked and
deeply worried over a thing that should
not panic or worry them we all must live
under their rule that's the way this
works alrighty we'll be back here later
today with an additional hour of content
coming up soon as the matt wall show it
airs at 1 30 pm eastern be sure to check
it out over at dailywire.com i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover and our production manager
is pavo wydowski associate producer
bradford carrington editing is by adam's
high events audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is by fabiola
christina production assistant jessica
crand the ben shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire
on the matt wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show